if we acknowledge that lighting isn't
just about visibility it can be about
creating atmosphere we can do so much
more if you've ever walked into a room
with harsh clinical lighting it can feel
cold and unwelcoming I know I definitely
have and it really sucks now picture
that same room with warm and inviting
lighting something similar to the lights
behind me right now it changes the
entire mood it makes the space feel cozy
and comfortable the secret is in the
color and temperature of the lighting a
3,000 Calin warm light emits a natural
comforting glow on the other hand a
6,000 Calin daylight white is clinical
harsh and unwelcoming here's where it
gets exciting again because everyone
loves a little bit of clever Tech with
smart bulbs and control systems you can
have the best of both worlds set your
lights to Bright and white during the
day for productivity and shift to warm
whites in the evening for relaxation